hey youtubers it's Charlie so the
Deadpool writers have already started
talking about Deadpool and cable the
sequel cables character how it's all
gonna work out so this is gonna be a big
explainer and I'll explain a little bit
about who cable is because he's a really
cool character that just hasn't been in
the movies yet careful for spoilers from
the Deadpool movie if you haven't seen
it yet I'm just gonna talk a little bit
about stuff during that this is mostly
gonna be about the sequel and stuff that
the writers have been saying at the end
of the Deadpool movie he does this big
Ferris Bueller's Day Off in tag Saint
Marie teases the cable is going to be
the sequel and true to form they are
actually writing cable into the sequel
they've started to explain because
everybody understands the cable is gonna
be in it it's not a secret they said
things that you would expect them to say
in order to keep the next movie
relatable it's still gonna be small
relatively self-contained yes cable is a
time-traveler but it's not gonna take
place a thousand years in the future
during Age of Apocalypse or anything
like that visually the time period will
just pick up sometime after the first
step pull movie it'll be during modern
day so it sounds like the budget is
gonna be relatively similar to what the
previous movie was they might give him a
little extra money for some special
effects but part of the reason why
Deadpool was so funny why the movie was
so funny is because of the things that
they could not do like oh it's almost
like the studio couldn't afford more
x-men those are some of the best jokes
in the film because they were completely
honest they did not have more money to
get more x-men so production wise even
though Deadpool and cable which is what
I'm gonna call the sequel for now is
gonna look almost the exact same as the
first movie that doesn't mean that
they're just gonna rehash the exact same
jokes just expect the same type of
energy really the new wrinkle is cable
in how his character changes the tone of
the film because if you've never read
cable you don't know anything about his
character he's like the polar opposite
of Deadpool Deadpool doesn't take
anything seriously cable takes
everything super seriously cable is
always trying to fight the end of the
world so he has zero sense of humor so
you already see where some of the comedy
comes from in the fact that he's forced
to deal with Deadpool he needs
Deadpool's help but he also wants to
kill him every time he opens his mouth
I've already talked about that New
Mutants 98 titled the first time
Deadpool debuted he shows up and kills
cables team the New Mutants the cables
been training for the last year all
these badass people then cable kills him
and Mail's the body parts literally
mails Deadpool's body
arts back to the person that hired
Deadpool's to kill the New Mutants when
they run into each other for the first
time in the cable and Deadpool comic
when they got their own title together
he immediately splatters Deadpool's
brains without even a thought
imagine the drill sergeant from Full
Metal Jacket being forced to team up
with Deadpool that's what cable and
Deadpool is like but thematically for
those that don't understand what's going
on with cables character way is all
about for the most part it's kind of a
terminator story there's always somebody
in the future some evil mutant that
takes over
during cable storyline that ends up
being strife strife is a clone of cable
that as a baby is stolen by apocalypse
and raised to be evil so it becomes this
big villain of the future and cables
mission is eventually to take stripe
down to kill himself essentially that
was actually my first introduction to
the cable character the big strife arc
happened during executioner song so you
can read that storyline if you want to
read all about strife but the other big
storyline that most people remember
cable from especially in recent memory
is Messiah Complex it gets really
complicated but that title really does
describe cables character he has a
Messiah Complex he's always trying to
save mutant kind but it involves a lot
of time travel so imagine the Terminator
movies only done with x-men characters
where John Connor is cable and he's the
one jumping around a time trying to save
everyone
now even though cable is kind of like
the John Connor character the backstory
is quite quite a bit different his real
name is Nathan summers and he's the son
of Cyclops and Madeline Pryor why did
Scott Summers wind up getting married
too and having a baby with a Jean Grey
look-alike that's already a complicated
story by itself after the Dark Phoenix
saga Cyclops really sad because he's
lost his lover meets a new woman and
falls in love she just happens to look
just like Jean Grey you can hear the
sound of all the comic book readers
doing double takes eventually they get
to Bonin and then in the future Nathan
summers was born but he gets wrapped up
in this big apocalypse storyline with a
techno-organic virus and strife has spun
out of that storyline but basically
that's how cable came into being Jean
Grey was dead Cyclops fell in love with
the Jean Grey look-alike they had a baby
when he first appeared in the comics he
debuted in uncanny x-men in that title
then he took the name cable and appear
New Mutants they were a team that cable
was training the fight strife in the
future but remember Deadpool shows up
kills a bunch of them and then in the
wake of that cable rebuilds the team and
rebrands it as x-force that became the
x-force comic book it sold five million
copies but remember that was during the
speculator boom if you guys don't know
what that is or if you're too young to
remember it it was when they could trick
you into buying multiple copies of a
single story by putting a different
cover on the front now because I'm
hoping they brand the sequel is Deadpool
and cable they might do something from
the Deadpool and cable stories that was
basically like cables second run cable
got his own solo series after that they
paired him up with Deadpool and that
became the Deadpool in cable comic book
now there are a couple things from the
comic book I don't think they're gonna
be able to do like cable turns his
spaceship he has this really cool
spaceship that he turns into a floating
island that's kind of like a new x-men
base no way the Deadpool movies gonna
have enough money to do something like
that automatically cable just tries to
use his powers to change the past to
make a better future so in the cable
movie they might have cable doing stuff
like that what about the big villain
though is it going to be like Batman V
Superman where they fight each other
there has to be a big bad of the film
that is not cable at a certain point so
if they really want to get crazy it
would be awesome if they did strife
because you could use the exact same
actor it'd be a little bit cheaper for
them so they can weave in some of the
comic-book history but they could make
it smaller more self-contained in their
original execution or song story the
next x-men film is introducing
apocalypse apocalypse is a big part of
cables backstory they could connect some
of those things but I think it's still
gonna be relatively self-contained
they want the big x-men films to be
their own thing they want Deadpool to be
its own thing even though there is a lot
of characters crossing over in Deadpool
making a lot of jokes about x-men
timeline problems McAvoy or Stewart so
hard to keep track of all the timelines
so whatever they end up doing just
expect it to be a simpler self-contained
version of a cabel storyline from the
comics let me know in the comments
though what stuff from the comics do you
want them to do for the Deadpool sequel
and who do you want to play cable I know
Stephen Lang has been lobbying for the
role that doesn't mean that he's been
cast they're probably looking at him
because he's not a super expensive actor
but he has played a lot of characters
that embody qualities the Cable has most
of you
we know him from the Avatar movie is the
villain to that movie think of a less
evil version of that that's kind of what
cables personality is like whatever ends
up happening just expect liberal back to
the future liberal terminator jokes it's
gonna be so much fun to have an
announced to release date yet but
because they're already writing the
movie the chances are pretty good they
could be finished with it in the next 18
months depending on how long
post-production takes I don't think
they'd be able to turn over a movie in a
single year so I don't think we'll see
it before summer of next year but
because it is a smaller film than the
x-men films they will be able to turn it
over faster my next Deadpool video might
be some x-force related stuff that's
gonna be a separate movie all by itself
that'll probably come after the Deadpool
sequel because they want to introduce
the Cable character then he can go off
and be an x-force and lead that team
just like you did in the comics if you
have any requests for Deadpool videos
just let me know in the comments be sure
to subscribe to get everything
there's a new legends of tomorrow
tonight cisco is guest starring from the
flash i don't know what he's gonna be
doing but it's gonna be a big Prison
Break episode wait you guys wait for me
to post that video you can click here
for all my Deadpool Easter eggs and you
can click here to learn all about
guardians of the galaxy - thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five let's go eat some tacos
you